LEON NICHOLLS: Have
you ever wished
that you could click on
things in the real world
to find out more about them?
What if you could learn
about things around you
in the real world
without doing a search?
You're at a bus stop.
What if you could click on the
stop to get the bus schedule?
You see a poster.
What if you could
click on the poster
so you can get more information?
What if the real world
behaved like the web?
Well, it can.
It's called the physical web.
So I'm curious.
How many of you have heard of
the physical web before today?
Just a show of hands.
OK, that's pretty
good, actually,
because the physical web
is still kind of new.
So what is this physical web?
It's a bridge between
physical things and the web.
It allows you to walk up to
anything and just use it.
So that sounds a little
magical, doesn't it?
How does this actually work?
So it starts with a beacon,
something like this.
It's broadcasting a URL.
The Chrome browser
on your mobile device
is scanning for URLs nearby.
When it finds one, it
creates a notification.
The user can then click
on the notification
and load the web page
associated with that URL.
The web page can present
some information,
and that web page also
connects to the device,
the beacon itself.
Let's look at an example.
So here we have a
vending machine.
We have a beacon associated
with this vending machine.
And the beacon is
broadcasting a URL,
and a notification is
displayed to the user
on the mobile
device for that URL.
It tells the user, hey, there's
a vending machine nearby.
You can buy candy.
So the user clicks
on the notification,
it loads this web page
with a big Buy button,
and the user can then
click on the Buy button.
When that happens, the
web page can communicate
with the vending machine
and say, hey, give
some candy to this guy.
So that's the user experience.
But how do you, as a developer,
implement the physical web
solution?
That's what this talk is about.
So I'm going to cover
several topics-- firstly,
how to configure and deploy
the beacons in the real world;
how to provide the metadata
from the notifications that
are displayed to the user; how
you can use progressive web
apps to create
native experiences;
and then how to use the Web
Bluetooth API to control
physical devices.
So let's start at the beginning.
So how do you actually
configure and deploy
a beacon in the real world?
So we're going to look
at some of the details,
and some of this is based
on our own experiences
with deploying beacons
in the real world.
In fact, one of my colleagues,
Scott, just recently
deployed some beacons at the
Computer History Museum, which
is somewhere in that direction.
And we learned some
valuable lessons from that.
Firstly, let's talk
about Eddystone.
So Eddystone is an open protocol
specification for beacons.
It defines a Bluetooth
Low Energy messaging
format for beacons.
So the beacons are
broadcasting URLs regularly,
and any nearby
applications can use that.
So Eddystone defines
several different types,
frame types that you can use
individually or in combination.
One of those frame types
is called Eddystone URL.
It allows you to
broadcast a URL.
That's what makes the physical
web possible with a beacon.
Now, Eddystone is
supported by all
the major beacon manufacturers,
and it's growing.
And Eddystone is also compatible
with Apple's iBeacon format.
OK, let's look at some
of the gory details.
So this is an advertising
packet, the actual bytes
that make up the advertisement
packets for the Eddystone URL
frame.
So this is what gets
broadcast by the beacon
on a regular basis.
So you can see that
we're broadcasting
a URL from the
Google URL shortener,
but you can use any shortener.
The URL is compressed to fit
within the limited advertising
packet size, which is
only 18 bytes for the URL.
Now, these advertising
packets are broadcast,
and any devices or
applications nearby
can extract useful
information from that.
So let's talk about Chrome.
Now, as I said, Chrome
in the background
is scanning for URLs nearby.
When it gets the
URL, it sends it up
to the cloud to a proxy service.
The proxy service
does several things.
Firstly, it eliminates the
duplicates, it avoids spam,
and it also does some
ranking of the URLs.
Now, the scanning is
done in the background
in a very efficient manner.
It doesn't drain your battery
for your mobile device.
And once the proxy
server has actually
processed all these URLs,
they are sent back to Chrome,
and then Chrome makes a
notification out of that.
Other browser vendors are also
working on their own scanners
to do something similar.
OK, you've bought
an Eddystone beacon
from any of the manufacturers
that support the standard.
How do you actually
configure that beacon
for the physical web?
Well, you start by
configuring the frame type.
So typically, a beacon
vendor will give you
a native app that
allows you to configure
their particular beacons.
So you open that app.
You configure the frame type.
You will then get prompted
to specify the URL.
There are some
requirements for the URL.
In particular, for the
physical web on Chrome,
we only support HTTPS,
for security reasons.
And as I mentioned
before, you've
got to use a URL shortener,
because there is only
a limited number of
bytes that you can put
into the advertising packet.
Now, the other advantage
of using a URL shortener
is that you can
do URL redirects.
So you can configure
all your beacons
with this shortened version of
the URL, and then at any time
go to the cloud and
change the URL redirect
without having to go back to the
beacons and reconfigure them.
So it's very valuable.
A few more parameters you
need to configure, again,
using the configuration app.
The first one is the
transmission power.
Now, we recommend
a value somewhere
between negative 35db
and negative 35db.
And so that's a low setting
for the transmission power.
It has two advantages.
One, it helps to
prolong the life
of the battery for the beacon.
Secondly, it ensures that
users only see the beacons when
they're close to the beacon.
So this gives the user a much
more contextual experience.
Now, of course, there are
going to be situations
where you need to extend
the transmission power,
have a higher value.
And I'll talk about some
of those use cases later.
The next parameter
that you need to set
is the advertising frequency.
We recommend a value
of 700 milliseconds.
So that means every
700 milliseconds,
the beacon is
advertising the data.
Now, scanning applications
such as Chrome
might not reliably show
these URLs as notifications
if this frequency is
slower than a second.
So this is really important.
What you need to do is, once
you've configured your beacons,
is go and actually try this
under real-world conditions,
and you might have to tweak
some of these parameters.
If these beacons are not
configured correctly,
the user experience
might not be good.
They might walk past your beacon
and never get a notification.
OK.
You've configured the beacon.
How do you actually
physically deploy
the beacon in the real world?
Now, the complexity
of your deployment
will depend on two
things-- firstly,
how many beacons you need
to deploy; and secondly,
how many distinct URLs
you need to support
for your particular application.
So this table shows the
various combinations,
and we'll go through those.
The first one is
really the easiest one.
It's where you've got
one beacon and one URL.
So that's like a
poster, and the poster
has a link to a trailer
for the movie, for example.
We recommend a low setting
for the transmission power.
Put the beacon at
a high altitude,
so there is less interference.
Also try and avoid any metal.
The next one is many
beacons, one URL.
So that's like having an
agenda at a conference.
That's exactly what
we've done here at I/O.
So I'm sure you've
seen on your phone
that there's notifications
coming up for the I/O agenda.
Now, of course, this
is a large area,
so we need a lot of
beacons to cover the area.
So here we recommend
you actually increase
the transmission power for the
beacon to cover a larger area.
Now, for physical web
scanners like Chrome,
when they see multiple
URLs in the same area,
it will be de-duplicated.
So even if there's overlap
between the transmissions,
the user will only see one URL.
So the next one is many
beacons, many URLs.
Now, the use case for this
is like an exhibition,
maybe like a museum.
So you've got a large building,
but a lot of individual items.
And you want to give
each item its own URL.
So in this case,
you want to restrict
the range in which
the user will actually
discover the URL for every
object as they walk around.
So you can do this by
lowering the transmission
power of the beacon.
OK.
You've configured the beacons.
You've deployed the beacons.
Now, how do you actually
provide the metadata
for those notifications that
get displayed to the user?
Now, the physical web
is an open ecosystem,
so any browser can
implement support for it.
But we're going to focus
on Chrome's implementation.
So let's take a look
at the notifications.
You can see that for
every URL discovered,
we see an icon,
some kind of image.
We see a title, we
see a description,
and of course, the URL
that was discovered.
But where is this coming from?
Well, remember, after Chrome
has collected the URLs nearby,
it's taking the shortened URL,
expands it into the full URL,
sends it up to
the proxy service.
The proxy service
actually goes and visits
every one of those URLs.
It then extracts the
metadata it needs.
And I'll go into the
details of what that is.
Once it's got the metadata, it
sends it back down to Chrome.
And then Chrome caches it
locally on the mobile device
and uses that for the
notification presentation.
One note that on, for Chrome, at
least, the physical web is not
enabled by default. So the
first time Chrome discovers
a physical web URL nearby, it
actually shows an introduction
to the feature.
It tells the user
about the physical web,
and it also asks permission
to enable the feature.
So only if the user
says yes, then they
will get subsequent
notifications
about nearby URLs.
OK.
So how do you
optimize your website
for these notifications
for the metadata?
Now, these are all based
on standard HTML concepts,
and I'm going to show you
an example of this, too.
Firstly, you need an HTML title.
You're going to need a
description meta tag.
You need an icon of at
least 96 by 96 pixels.
So where is that
number coming from?
Well, we've done some
testing, and anything lower
than that doesn't
really look good
as a notification on
most mobile devices.
So at least that dimension.
Now, if you don't provide the
title or the description meta
tag, you can also use
Schema.org or Open Graph
tags to provide that metadata.
We're also considering
the use of a web app
manifest for some
of the metadata.
It's not there yet, but
will be coming soon.
OK, so what does this mean?
Well, here's the most basic
HTML to provide all the metadata
we need for a notification.
It's really quite simple.
So you can see we have the
title, we have the description,
we have a reference to the icon
and a reference to the web app
manifest.
This is standard web stuff.
Let's look at the app manifest.
In particular, we are interested
in two of those values,
the name and the set of icons.
So this is just a JSON
file that shows you
the metadata about the web app.
This is not particular
to physical web.
This is just part of
the web standards.
The nice thing
about the icons is
that it shows
multiple resolutions,
so that are very useful with
showing different resolutions
on the mobile devices.
OK.
So now you've got your website
ready for the notification,
right?
You threw out all the metadata.
When the user clicks
on their notification,
your web page is then loaded.
Now, one of the
criticisms of web apps
is that the user experience
and the set of features
that are possible
from a web page
might not match that
of a native app.
In particular, when
it comes to things
like usability or
responsiveness,
it might not be as
good as native apps.
Well, that's actually
no longer true.
And we're going to look at
how we can use progressive web
apps to create native
experiences for users.
So let's take just a quick
look at what progressive web
apps are.
Firstly, it supports
a full-screen mode
for your web app.
Your app can be added as
an icon to the home screen.
So the user can
launch it directly
without using the
browser directly.
It supports push notifications.
It has an application cache.
In fact, you can cache
the entire application--
the framework, the data,
everything-- locally
on the mobile device.
And that's great, because
you can do something
called offline support.
So literally, when your
mobile device is not
connected to the
internet in any way,
you'll still be able
to launch this app,
and the user will not see
any error messages, no
HTTP error codes.
It will launch like it is
connected to the internet.
So support for
progressive web apps
are being implemented by
Chrome, Firefox, and Opera.
Progressive web apps are
a really great example
of leveraging existing web
technologies for a new use
case.
OK, let's take a
look at an example.
This is a progressive web app.
You can see that the user
is loading it from a URL.
Then it's added to the
home screen as an icon.
And once you launch it from that
icon, it launches full screen.
There's no address
bar, and to the user,
it actually looks
like a native app.
So that's quite different
from a normal web page.
So this is an example of
a great progressive web
app from a physical-web
point of view.
And the reason is that
this particular app
is single-purpose.
So in this case, it actually
allows you to press a button.
Now, ideally, when you design a
web page for the physical web,
you should cater
to a single action.
Remember, the user just
clicked on the notification
for that beacon.
The user has shown
an intent to interact
with that beacon or device.
So the user is not
browsing to this page,
or won't be browsing
inside the page.
So ideally, focus on providing
either a simple action
or a single page of content that
is associated with that beacon
or device.
OK.
So you have a web app.
How do you make it progressive?
There's actually just three
things you need to do.
It's quite simple.
Firstly, you need to add
something called a service
worker.
So has any of you heard of
a service worker before?
OK, just some of you.
OK.
A service worker is
something quite new.
A very exciting
technology, though.
What it does-- it's like running
a script in the background
for your website.
Chrome does this on your behalf.
Now, the main use case
for a service worker,
or one of the main use
cases, is to do caching.
So once you've configured
the service worker,
you can configure it
so it can automatically
cache your framework and
data behind the scenes.
And that makes the
offline support possible.
Now, there are various
libraries and frameworks,
like Polymer, that
allows you to easily add
this to existing web app,
so this is not a big effort.
The second requirement--
you have to use HTTPS.
Now, as I mentioned before,
for the physical web scan
on Chrome, we only
support HTTPS,
so you have to do that anyhow.
Then the third
thing you have to do
is you have to provide
the web app manifest.
So again, as I
mentioned earlier,
we're looking into supporting
the web app manifest for some
of the metadata.
So there's a nice overlap
between the requirements
of the physical web and
progressive web apps.
Now, those are just
the basics, actually.
There's a lot more
to progressive apps.
But that's basically all you
need for this particular use
case for the physical web.
There are things that you
can provide for configuring
the offline support.
There's more things you can
do with the service worker.
There's a growing number
of libraries and frameworks
and some great sample apps.
In fact, there's been
several sessions here
at I/O about
progressive web apps.
So if you're interested
in exploring opportunities
to make your web
app be more native,
then definitely go and
look at those resources.
We've also announced
more frameworks that
support progressive
web apps and also
a lot more content partners
that are now developing
progressive web apps.
OK.
So we've configured beacons.
We've deployed beacons.
We've got the metadata.
The user is clicking
on our notification,
because we've got
something that is enticing,
and the user wants to interact
with that particular device
or beacon.
So now that the user has
actually loaded the web page
from a Bluetooth
device, your page
can actually communicate back
to that Bluetooth device.
And you can do that using an API
called the Web Bluetooth API.
So I'm going to show you my
very first Web Bluetooth API
application.
Can we play the video, please?
So here's my Chromebook.
I've got a web app there,
and there's a control panel.
And there's Grumpy.
Grumpy is attached to
some helium balloons,
and I've got a little
Bluetooth controller on there.
And this controller is
interesting in that it
has a little propeller.
[LAUGHTER]
And we're going to see if
we can make Grumpy fly.
So this particular
device has a way for you
to control the speed of the
propeller and the rudder.
You control the
direction left and right.
So here I'm first
connecting to the device.
Now that it's connected, I
can make Grumpy do stuff.
What are we going to do?
So I'm just setting
the rudder, and I'm
starting the little engine.
And you should see
Grumpy start moving.
Can you see the little
propeller going there?
It was really tricky
controlling this.
It's not that easy
to move it around.
But there you get the idea.
Poor Grumpy.
Grumpy is flying.
So that's all doing basically
Bluetooth from a web page
directly to a device.
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
So let's talk about this magic.
What is the Web Bluetooth API?
So the Web Bluetooth
API is a specification
that allows you to
talk from a web page
to a device in a
very secured way.
And secondly, it allows you to
communicate and control devices
using Bluetooth Low Energy.
So this is a standard,
Bluetooth Low Energy,
that that's been
around for a while.
Now, on web pages
that use this API,
the user actually gets
prompted to select a device
to connect to.
Now, that's a little awkward
for the physical web use case--
because remember, the user has
clicked on the notification--
if they go to a page, and
then we prompt the user again
to connect, when
the user has already
kind of indicated an intent
to talk to that device.
So we're working on
a solution for that,
an update that will come soon
that will actually avoid that.
So if the notification
launches a page that
then goes to the web
page or to the device,
we won't show that
chooser to the user.
So it's a seamless experience.
But at the moment,
it does show that.
Now, this is actually
a very exciting API.
It's a lot of fun to play with.
And previously, the only
way you could do Bluetooth
is to have a native app.
Now you can do it from the web.
OK.
So previously,
remember I told you
that when you had to
configure a beacon,
you had to use the configuration
app from the beacon
manufacturer.
It's a native app, typically.
Well, now that we have
the Web Bluetooth API,
can't we use that to
configure the beacon?
And the answer is
yes, we can, actually.
So there is something called
the Eddystone URL Configuration
Service.
It allows you to set the
Eddystone URL parameters
and transmission characteristics
that we looked at earlier.
This web app here at that
URL was written by one
of my colleagues, Francois.
And it lets you fully configure
all the parameters you
need for the physical
web, and it's
using the Web Bluetooth API.
So this is really great, because
now you can use this single web
app to go and
configure any beacon
from any manufacturer that
supports this configuration
service.
Very nice.
[APPLAUSE]
Now, the Web Bluetooth
API in this particular app
works on Chrome OS.
It works on Chrome
for Android M.
It works on Chrome for Linux.
And we're working on
support for Windows
and Mac OS X. We want
this to work everywhere.
OK, let's look at code.
So how do you use the API?
The API is actually very easy.
So the first
section of the code,
we're providing what's
called a faulter.
And we're basically telling
the scanner for the Bluetooth
devices that we're
interested in a device nearby
that's supporting a service
called the warp engine service.
OK?
So Chrome will find it.
It'll show a list to the user.
The user picks it
from the chooser.
And once the user has selected
it, the rest of the code
is run asynchronously.
The first thing we need to do
is actually make the connection.
And then we do two more things.
We try and find a service.
In this case, we are trying to
find the warp engine service.
And once we've got the
warp engine service,
we can get the warp
factor characteristic.
Now, the terminology
I'm using here
is all standard Bluetooth
Low Energy concepts.
This is not particular
to the Web Bluetooth API.
Of course, the warp engine
is not a standard service.
Once we've got the
characteristic,
we can read values from
that characteristic.
In this case, we are reading
the warp factor value
from that characteristic.
The API also allows you to
write values to the beacon.
And it has a mechanism to
notify your code asynchronously
when values change.
So as you can see, very simple.
This is it.
This is the working code.
The rest of it is
just making the UI.
So it's very simple,
but very powerful.
And this works with any
device that supports BLE.
Let's look at another cool demo.
So I wrote a sample
app that allows you
to control a [INAUDIBLE] toy.
And one of my
colleagues, Matthew,
took this to the next level with
this really awesome web app.
So I'm going to do a demo.
Can we switch to
the demo, please?
OK.
If we can make that out?
So this is a web page.
And when you load
the page, it actually
prompts you to
connect to a device.
So let's try and do that.
And there is the chooser.
And what are we choosing?
Well, we're choosing Ali.
So Ali is a Bluetooth device.
So that it happens to be its ID.
And now we're going to pair it.
So we are pairing it, and
then the code is connecting.
It's running basically that code
that I showed you, of course
not the same characteristics.
And so to show you this,
I'm going to put it here,
and hopefully you can see it.
So I'm going to use the UI to do
some interesting things to Ali.
So there I'm
changing the colors.
And I'm going to do
something very dangerous.
I'm going to actually
try and move Ali.
Scary.
OK.
Hope you get the idea.
So Ali is actually
designed to run around,
but I'm not going to
make it run around.
I think I'm going to
freak out the cameraman.
So what I did there was
just use the controller here
to move Ali.
And so it's turning
around as I'm
adjusting the controller
and then the color.
There's a little color
wheel to go and change
the color of the device.
OK.
Can we go back to
the slides, please?
[APPLAUSE]
Here are some other
Web Bluetooth API
apps that I created.
They're all
open-source on GitHub.
So there's a racing car.
There's a little printer
and a little LED device.
Now, these are all
off-the-shelf devices.
No hacking required.
They support BLE.
Go and have fun.
OK.
So now you know how to implement
a physical web solution, right?
We've covered all
the aspects of it.
But why?
Why would you want to do
a physical web solution?
What are the opportunities
for you as a developer?
Now, remember, Eddystone
is an open protocol.
Everything about Eddystone
and the physical web
has been open-sourced.
All of our code is
sitting on GitHub.
Go and take a look.
The physical web works
across multiple beacons,
multiple browsers,
multiple operating systems.
Everything that I
showed you today
doesn't require you to
use anything from Google.
Now, the physical
web is also ideal
for long-tail applications.
Your user doesn't have to
download an app and install it.
You don't have to
maintain that native app.
The user experience for the
physical is also consistent.
It's always, there's
a notification,
the user clicks on
the notification,
it loads a web page.
The web page can do
amazing things now.
So that's great from a user
education point of view.
Now, since you can do
Bluetooth from a web page,
now you have opportunities
you didn't have before,
because it opens up the whole
growing IoT market to you now,
as a developer.
You don't need to build
native apps to control
embedded devices anymore.
So let's do a recap.
The physical web is an open,
new, intuitive ecosystem.
It's all based on
open standards.
We have Eddystone, which is an
open beacon messaging format.
You can control Bluetooth
devices, Bluetooth LE.
Eddystone beacons can be
configured to support URLs.
They broadcast in the
URLs, and anybody around it
can pick it up and do
what they want with that.
That makes the
physical web possible.
Various browsers and
operating systems
are implementing support for
this and scan for the URLs
nearby.
And when the user clicks on
notifications for those URLs,
it loads a web page.
That web page can be loaded by
any browser, not just Chrome.
So this is really a
very exciting area
to explore and very
easy to get started.
So what's next?
Well, go and play.
It's a lot of fun.
You have everything you
need to be able to do
this yourself right now.
So here are some useful links.
We've got a lot of
stuff on GitHub.
It's still very early
days for this technology,
so we'd love to
get your feedback.
Your feedback can
actually have an impact
on the direction in which
this technology will go.
And now the main reason
you're here, of course,
is the free stuff.
So we're handing out some
test beacons this afternoon.
It's in the Mobile Web Sandbox.
It's somewhere in
that direction.
So these are test
beacons, and they've
been loaded with firmware
that supports that Eddystone
configuration service
that I mentioned before.
So you can go to that web
page and go and configure
that beacon.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]